he's the head coach of the Indianapolis
Colts entering his second season as such
Frank Reich here on the Rich Eisen show
how are you coach I'm doing great
excellent fantastic
you're - what do you um I mean what do
you think you're one was like that
you're already looking to try and
tighten up just from your own
perspective as a head coach Frank I'll
tell you what it just feels the whole
office issues felt better different you
know just growing learning from
everything first year first and foremost
just learning about the players you know
developing the relationships
understanding you know who they are what
do we bring to the table with you know
the successes and failures that we've
had that we've learned from you know
system wise you know digging deeper into
our schemes on in all three phases just
feel like we're at a really good spot
going to the year - alright so let's
talk about some of these guys luck
Andrew Luck what what did you see from
him that reminded you of some of the
all-time greats that you've been
fortunate enough to play with and also
coach Frank several things you know when
I think about elite quarterback play
first thing I always think about is
toughness you know mentally and
physically just having this this
tenacity this grit this this will to win
was just second to none and second
anomaly Andrews got that seeing that you
know I've admired it from afar but now
to see it when we have one in five and
when his mindset is very positive very
team-oriented
that's number one number two elite
accuracy you know as a quarterback you
know I've had the good fortune of being
on some really accurate quarterbacks in
my days and you need that to be elite
and and he's got that and then thirdly
he's got what we like to refer to as
accelerated vision meaning Jesus process
and he can process information really
quick it's not just that he's smart he
can just manage all this information
really fast and make really good
decisions and do you I guess speak a
different language just because you are
quarterbacks that it's easier for you to
communicate with him as a head coach to
him
I do think that I do think that helps
our you know our relationship and the
coach player thing you know the
experience there it's not everything but
it certainly is I think a big part of it
you know we're two or three steps down
the road in those discussions I think
because of because of that experience
Frank Reich here on the Rich Eisen show
in terms of nastiness where does Quentin
Nelson rank on people that you've again
played with and coached we see it on
film I'm wondering what it is like to
have a front-row seat for that sort of
thing
well kind of cool Quentin he's not only
nasty like you remember back in the old
days there were I'm not going to name
any names there were guys that you would
say nasty and that almost meant nasty
was synonymous with they had some dirty
play in there Quentin doesn't play dirty
he's just nasty and it's physically
plays by the rules he just physically is
a dominant player and that attitude is
pretty infectious on our team yeah I
mean certainly in the line play I mean
you got to be able to just say you know
what I'm gonna I'm gonna destroy the
individual right across from me and
that's a tone setter and in terms of
that when I say nasty I did not mean
dirty I meant just stealing another
individual soul is basically what I had
right there so in terms of that who is
the that person you've you played with
behind or watch to play defense that
that ranks number one that you were that
you played with from your playing days
that would steal someone's soul that I
played with there's some universe Smith
who would certainly be up there I mean
that guy was you know he just had a way
Bruce was as a competitor he was he was
the best you know I mean he just was
going to figure out a way to steal you
like you said risk
for him stealing your soul was it might
not be running you over but he was going
to figure out a way to dominate you and
that might be running around you it
might be doing it it might be running
through you but he was so physically
gifted and and but yet had had this
capacity and instincts as a player that
he just he just figured out how to
dominate his opponent yeah I mean
Marshall Faulk tells a story about how
you know the field in Buffalo I was sort
of like a crown to it and and Bruce
would come out of the tunnel with the
heat coming off or just the heat coming
off not just it's hot because it's cold
too you know off people's heads and he
would stroll out with his arms all
greased up and everybody would just look
at each other and go oh this is a
problem for all of us and you know what
the further away that I get from seeing
what he did and getting a chance to you
know be in the same draft class as
burgers right you know watching through
the years to really appreciate what he
did it just keeps getting bigger and
better to me that how dominant he was
you know even when he's playing in the
3-4 scheme I know who's lined up at
defensive end a fair amount too but he's
playing five technique you know we get
two hundred sacks that's just crazy well
I mean Frank you mean you knowing him
anybody who's come across Bruce
certainly if he just does end up late
you know later on have a cocktail he
will tell you that he played in the
three-four scheme getting 200 sacks and
he will tell you that that makes him a
unique individual I mean he's not very
shot employment no he wasn't very shy
and pointing it out that he was going to
get two hundred sacks I remember him
telling us that you know that he was
gonna no kidding that was a goal that he
was going to end up as the sack leader
and he just had this will to dominate
and compete that not many guys have hear
this at a very high level well before we
get back to the the front and center in
the present day with you Frank Reich how
often do you think about that that that
victory in the playoffs overcoming the
Oilers do you do
think about it often do you use it as a
coach in any way shape or form the
comeback of the ages that you author you
know just just the lessons from it you
know just the lessons from it as far as
team you know at the top you and the
team and the preparation and the belief
you know in the police and then the
philosophy of one play at a time that
more than anything and that carries over
to how how I coach how I play how I
think about anything that you know we
got a lot of hype last year a lot of
talk about that one and ou slogan that
and get 1% better last year that was
kind of our mantra well that's kind of
with the REC flow out of that one play
at a time I mean I I just don't see any
other way to approach it
I know everybody says it but our goal is
as as a team is to really embody that
that that mindset more than anything
else well I mean it worked you went from
one in five to the playoffs I mean did
you did you mention your personal
comeback in that game obviously a lot of
people would know it did you use that
specifically to dig out of a one in five
hole at any point in time yeah no I
didn't you know I think guys know that
but you know shoot we have a couple
other players on our team who have some
pretty more answer has a pretty good
comeback that's right and and and you
know as a coach yeah you're a tional II
I would occasionally pull out an old
story but what I try to do is occur I
try I want to know they're my players
I'm on another player stories that this
game is about these players and I think
as coaches you know let me learn what
their story is let let's highlight that
sure we're going to learn from past
experiences and every coach is bringing
bringing my past experiences to bear I
think everybody knows that and
understands that but at the end of the
day you know this is about us doing
something special together and creating
that that kind of mindset you know every
day I practice and then that's what
leads to coming back from one and five
to you at any point in time notice the
fact that you did make that comeback and
end at Houston season at the same time
last year did that dawn upon you Frank
I'm sure I mean you know you think about
those things but yeah I don't think
about them very long okay I don't think
about them very long just there's always
so much to do so much work to be done
the next the next step that has to be
taken the next day to figure out how to
get better right so that's more than
mindset okay did people in Houston ever
give you grief still a little bit a
little bit every now and then alright
let's talk about the present-day Frank
Reich the head coach in the Olympics
Indianapolis Colts you like that pass
interference is reviewable now were you
for that you know what I think we wrote
yeah I mean I think I think it's a good
step is it the perfect step I don't know
we'll figure it out I think it'll
continue to revise it and appreciate the
fact that the league is is exactly like
we were just talking about one to get
better try to figure out a way to
eliminate what we what happened in the
playoffs last year and it usually takes
several iterations to get to the final
process of that but this is a this is a
legitimate first step all right do you
have a plan I mean a lot of coaches as
we all know like the plan a plan and
when you think you're gonna use it use
the challenge flag offensive pass
interference also is up there for us up
so drives and not only that it could be
called because you're trying to review a
defensive pass interference and come
back that it's on your guy to begin with
your offensive player Frank this is
exactly and so ya know we're talking
about that quite a bit you know we have
two guys in our analytics department who
I talk to daily about a variety of
things and you know so we're always
talking through these scenarios on how
we're going to do that always those guys
are always looking at film thinking
through the strategy that when to
challenge when not to challenge looking
at all the situational components that
come into it it's hard to figure them
all out but that's why that's why you
got to have a couple guys that 24/7
night that's all they think about and
then we can process do that together all
right in a couple minutes I have left
with you here
coach Parris Campbell man oh man does
that guy run fast is that one way to put
it
how are you going to employ him in your
offense what are you gonna do with this
young talented rookie out of the Ohio
State here with you yeah we really are
excited about Paris not just like you
said Richie is really fast but what the
reason we drafted him where we did and
are so excited about him is we feel like
he's not only fast but he runs good
routes he's smart he has good hands he's
not just you know in Ohio State they
used him in a very good way they used
them in a hybrid slot kind of gadget
receiver and he'll certainly do some of
that for us but we see a guy who's going
to develop into a legitimate NFL
receiver not just a gadget guy not just
a slot receiver guy who can play inside
around and really develop into the whole
real deal from head to toe so we think
that's kind of player we have so it's
not to be fair and balance because you
you signed Devin Funchess from Michigan
Frank you're not trying to just be fair
and balanced okay no we're not trying No
okay so so on that both they both
complement you know it's really exciting
offensive right honey ity Hilton to the
right and Eric Ebron and Jack Doyle
Marlin ma'am you know you know this is
this this is good stuff to think about
and so Paris were excited about him and
pontius man or you talk about big and
strong and long and good right one or so
more excited about the weapons we have
on offense and then last one for you
Darius Leonard you went talking you said
you and talked about players and stories
his is phenomenal what he was able to do
in year number one what are your
expectations for him in his second
campaign in the pros you know what I
love about there is you know I know he
knows he had a great year but you know
when you talk to him all he's talking
about how he's gonna get better and
become a better team and a better player
he just got this infectious energy on
you know talking to him you just got
this infectious energy no matter what
he's done if it's in a meeting if he's
out on the practice field the guy's a
real leader he just got this spirit that
this positive energy is positive outlook
on things I mean he just he's overcome a
lot in his life and
he just has this way about him that
makes him not only a great player but a
great leader so I'm expecting him to
develop as boat he'll he'll continue to
get better as a player and as a leader
and I think make the guys around and
even better well you know what
championship teams look like Frank you
have one well I'll tell you here's what
we talked about we talked about
championship teams practice like
champions so we talked about
surrendering the results and and the
outcome to focus on the process so to
the extent that we can practice like
champions and meet like champions and
prepare like champions that's the only
we believe that's what will determine
that that's what will bring us the
results at the end of the day rather
than us trying to focus on what the
expectations are and how far we're going
to go let's have our expectations
focused on being champions at practice
and then that'll take us how far we can
go coach thanks for the time let's chat
down the line really appreciate it
anytime rich thank you you got it that's
Frank Wright for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 under
rec TV for free on VR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app